you know how many Democrat members are
afraid of being primaried by Squad
members or potential Squad members a lot
of them I kind of like that to be honest
but I'm just keeping it real you know
why Chuck Schumer Chuck Schumer was
acting you know was wilding out and
starting to say all these positions he
didn't want to be primaried by AOC
that's why I hope she doesn't and look
you know I love it me and Cortez I talk
to her every now and again but
Chuck Schumer I didn't want that smoke
I promise you that he didn't want that
action I gotta I gotta I gotta say about
AOC right one of the biggest issues I
have is she's talking about January 6
and she fabricated a story about what
happened so she says that she's in her
office and someone knocks on the door
and then she hides in the bathroom and
someone says where is she where is she
and all this stuff and
now you then you get the response from
the conservative saying she wasn't even
in the Capitol Building then you get the
response to the media saying yeah but
they're all connected then I looked at
this and I was like her story took place
an hour before the capital was even
breached why would she hide in the
bathroom thinking someone was coming for
her unless she knew in advance people
are going to break into the building or
her story is fake well I mean look she
you know she lives by the drama code of
politics you know it's like the other
thing where
she was at the protest in front of the
Supreme Court and she tried to fake like
she got arrested yeah she put her hand
inside she put her hands behind her back
and raised her hand I'm like come on sis
you ain't getting no cuffs on you
because if you did you could you know
it's stuff like that so she lives by the
drama of politics it is what it is but I
think that
what has happened in both parties
is that you've had the reflection of
Voters
who were tired of establishment politics
they're tired of being given a false
narrative or a half a narrative that
isn't really real that because there's
some deal cut up here in Capitol Hill
that the people don't know about they're
cut out of the process and so what we
call the squad on the other side is
really the the culmination of the Occupy
Movement a decade ago what you call
Freedom caucus members on our side is
really the Fulfillment of the Tea Party
wave 10 years ago
because voters on both sides of the
political Spectrum have had enough of
this business as usual in Washington D.C
that's actually a good thing so what's
happened in the Democrat Caucus is the
reason why it appears that the squad
just kind of goes along they've actually
moved their caucus
on a myriad of issues bruh they're out
here talking about how it's cool to dran
transgender kids
Joe Biden was that was not his position
a decade ago I promise you that but the
reason why he's got to be cool with that
now is because that is where the base of
his party has gone in part because of
members like the squad and activists in
the Democrat base
I feel like what's happened I feel like
that is a representation of uh
analogous to fire a chaotic destructive
force that is spreading I I think that
if you actually you know what I don't
think this I know this if you go to your
average American and you show them the
book genderqueer for instance have
you've heard about this book I've heard
about it and it's got graphic images in
it it's a pretty messed up book if you
read the whole thing too and it's it's
sad it's it's this woman was traumatized
but when I when I tell regular people
this and and we we live and work about a
half an hour away from where that big
Loudoun County fight was happening with
these schools they say that's not true I
say here is a physical copy of the book
open it up they look at it and they say
this had to have been one school and so
what you end up with is uh people like
the squad people in their activist base
which I believe represents a very small
percentage of this country who are
advocating for extremist policies either
open borders abolishing Private health
care child sex change operations things
like that and when you talk to regular
Americans they don't believe it's
actually happening right they don't I
don't they actually want to they
actually want to abolish Private health
care yes and not just establish a public
option they uh the public option was a
pathway to Universal Health Care always
was right so one of the weird things
when Scott Brown got elected in
Massachusetts the reason why Nancy
Pelosi just pushed for uh Obamacare the
Affordable Care Act as was is because
she understood that if they did the push
for a public option it would have
completely blown up the bill and there
would be no Obamacare so her position
was let's just get the thing we got
right now because we can't send it back
to the Senate because we don't have 60
votes anymore we got 59 and if it comes
back this way it's done and that's what
happened so they're still mad because
they thought the game plan was public
option because public option would have
eviscerated private insurance because
everybody would have just dumped people
into the public option that's what they
wanted gov but it didn't happen because
Scott Brown got elected that's that's
those are facts Bernie Sanders
campaigned during the during the 2020
election uh primaries not on creating a
private and public multi-faceted system
but outright abolishing all Private
health care which has never it's not
even like all the countries they tout in
Europe they have both they have both
yeah so I mean even my advocacy I've
been like you know if a kid gets the flu
I think it would be great if he could go
to the doctor and get Tamiflu if you
broke your arm you could go in and get
it taken care of and you don't got to
worry about going bankrupt I think a lot
of Americans worry about that stuff and
then if you get something like Advanced
lymphoma which requires expensive bills
you know a certain amount of it is
covered but there's limitations to what
we can provide so I'm not fully on board
with we can cure every disease for every
single person and I'm in the Middle
where it's like it'd be nice if people
had some basic level of coverage but
what what's being proposed by the
progressives is one of the most extreme
positions in the world right I
understand socialized emergency care if
someone falls down and breaks their arm
and they are poor you you help that
person but socialize chronic care when
which we basically have we have that and
that's cool because you want to save a
life saved life but when people eat
themselves into sickness and then I
expected the taxpayer to cover their
their injections of random Pfizer drugs
I'm not into it I don't want to pay for
people to eat sickness like sugar is
horrible for your body if you overdose
on that stuff I like Snickers man hold
on man you know I like Snickers don't do
that but I know your point I I see your
point I get your point I think the key
thing is is that you know the issue with
the Democrats is
it's never good enough
they constantly are pushing for the next
wave because what they fully ultimately
want is
complete control of the industry that's
what they want they'll never say that in
campaigns they'll never say that in
speeches but when you ask them well when
is enough enough they'll be like like
Joe Biden said the other day let's
finish the job well finish what job bro
you just spent five trillion dollars we
don't have we're at the debt ceiling now
you created a labor shortage in our
economy like when you pay people to stay
home what you do is create a labor
shortage what do I mean by that number
one you don't have to go work 40 hours
because there's money coming in from
somewhere else but you still have the
same amount of money to buy products
so people aren't working to the level
necessary to create all the products at
a certain cost but everybody's got money
to buy it
well what does that mean heavy demand
limited Supply means the prices go up
that's what's happened in the economy
Joe Biden did that if you had the
inflation reduction act which was like
one of the biggest misnomers in American
history that thing doesn't do anything
for inflation it was the green new
deal's little sister that's what it was
that was in that bill the inflation the
infrastructure bill was a Prelude to
build back better they just couldn't get
the votes because he wanted to spend too
much money if Joe manchin and Christian
Cinema were like yeah we're cool
spending another four trillion dollars
bill back better would have been law
facts that's the deal
so where we're at right now
you got to understand a couple things
one you cannot just spend money
recklessly the laws of Economics don't
change I don't care who you are I don't
care how well you speak I don't care how
cool you are I don't care what your fit
looks like you cannot spend money
unilaterally the laws that economics
don't change it hits everybody don't
believe me ask the Weimar Republic
so people people uh Super Chat us the
other day when he said let's finish the
job right we had a great Super Chat
sorry I forget I can't remember the name
of the individual who chatted us but he
said he's he's referring to jamming the
knife in the back of the of the Gasping
corpse of the economy he's saying let's
finish it off and to those that know his
policies have resulted in damage chaos
inflation Etc it sounds like he's saying
let's make it worse like I'm not Tim
foil hat guy that's not me like you know
I'm a city kid man I just I deal in
common sense my grandmother God Rest her
soul was from Jamaica she will always be
like Byron yeah five common sense boy
you must think right that was her I deal
in common sense but when you look at the
policy outcomes of where they want to
take us that's only because the only way
you can fundamentally make changes in
our economy which is the best by far the
best in the history of the world is you
have to make it so hard
to earn money you have to make it so
difficult to keep wealth
that there has to be some fix from
Washington D.C and the fix is only more
control up here with people who frankly
with all due respect to my colleagues
they don't have the intellect to manage
your life they don't have it I know what
one thing that they've done we got a
bunch of new people coming in is that is
that who that is a lot of the um when
they printed all this money they're
telling American people that trust us
modern monetary Theory but what's great
what the trick is is they're not
investing the money in infrastructure
programs production and things that's
monetary theory is that you put you
print 10 trillion dollars you put it
into stat factories so that you start
producing Goods that are worth more than
the 10 trillion they're not producing
the things they're just putting it in
bank accounts look let me be let me keep
it real simple about modern monetary for
every one of your listeners has got a
little brother or little sister
let them just spend whatever they want
regardless of how much money's in the
family's bank account How's that gonna
work
it's an unmitigated disaster and mom's
gonna be mad somebody's getting a
spanking I still believe in spanking I
got kids I spank my kids it's whatever
you know social media can get mad at me
but it is what it is somebody's in
trouble
you cannot just spend money
without any controls on what comes in
nobody can do that
if you borrow money incessantly you
create the situation where republics
have fallen that's what's happened to
too many republics in the history of the
world so when you have conservatives
like myself who say look control
spending make sure you're doing it the
right way when you do that you create
the environment for economies to thrive
for people to grow Etc real quick
because I'm gonna do the quick segue
because he usually segues for me I get
the opportunity to segue from him ladies
and gentlemen man sitting down in the
room right now
he is the Forerunner of what it means to
bring the diesel to question people this
is the guy you see with no jacket on but
a tie and a dress shirt he is the guy
that myself bobert and so many of us
have watched on TV and in committee
hearings grilling the Democrats day
after day after day this is one of the
forerunners of the conservative movement
in our country my good friend The
Honorable from Ohio Jim Jordan Byron
thank you Tim good to be with you yeah
I'm doing fine
Byron's doing the interview here now
he's dead Oh that's oh listen I've been
down there I've been down to Naples and
talked to all his Republican buddies I
was gonna start though
with what is it called chicken City yeah
so my wife she she literally built we
have eight Acres out in the country
around her family's Farm she built her I
call it the Taj Mahal she built her own
chicken coop from scratch she did it all
and now we have the security camera
stuff up but she can watch her chickens
via security cameras so we got we got
great eggs and all but I understand you
guys are this is this is your thing too
so it's amazing yeah we have a chicken
City we've got I think 30 or so chickens
we've got a camera you can watch them
all day there's be a couple but now it's
just one watching them all do their
chicken stuff yeah you know chickens are
hilarious yeah so she's had to save uh
come out yelling to get the fox away
because sweet you know she had started
with what nine and she's down to five
but we still get plenty of eggs I don't
know if you do that they probably do
that Naples
I go to the supermarket and get the eggs
yeah I appreciate it ours are cheaper
ours are cheaper right now you know I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna come by the
cheaper yeah because you know I got sons
and they eat like eggs all the time
because they're all lifting weights and
whatnot and I'm out on that training
they're training all the time real quick
I want to ask you this one question and
then I'm gonna turn it over because I'm
not an interviewer I I answer too many
questions these days
my question for you
and I've never asked you this question
what what was the thing what was the aha
moment that made you realize that
conservatism was the path forward to for
the country
um I mean I was raised in a conservative
family although my dad was a Democrat he
was a union worker for General Motors
and and like a lot of Americans in 1980
decided enough of this Democrat stuff
he's gonna he's gonna vote for the
Reagan guy
um but raising a conservative kind of
Christian home and but for me it's
probably Athletics you know um the idea
in America is you know you you set a
goal you work hard and you you try to
accomplish things and that seemed to fit
with conservatism and my background's a
sport of wrestling I wanted to play
football but I'm five seven and a half
on a good day so I had to wrestle
um but yeah it's probably wrestling
because it's all about competition I
think it's one of the problems in the
country today is
people you don't have people competing
and frankly I don't think you have
enough people just involved in being
tough no one gets in a fighting school
anymore you know enough kids playing
football or wrestling I think that's a
problem so
probably probably came from my my
background in the sport of wrestling
because I started when I was
in third grade and did it for the for
the longest time did you want to be a
professional wrestler Jim no there's no
real professional wrestling in amateur
wrestling you you know I wanted to be at
stage I never wanted to be a WWE
Champion no that's for
I'm gonna give up the headset in the
microphone so I went to a WWE event oh
golly in my district right yeah because
I like I actually like pro wrestling
yeah it's a thing for me I like the
Showmanship and all like it's fun it's
interesting so I go in the locker room
right they gave me like the treatment
they're like we're gonna bring
superstars in to meet with you I was
like okay cool you know the thing I
realized I'm bigger than most of the
dudes on the roster I got pictures with
Big E who was a WWE champion at the time
before he broke his neck because
somebody did a suplex and they messed
him up hopefully you know shot the
biggie hopefully he comes back
but I took a picture with the Money in
the Bank briefcase I got a picture and
I'm like three interest taller and I'm
like thicker than him and I'm like oh I
could do this yeah the only you know WWE
people I know are the ones who are in
real wrestling uh Gable Stevenson was
three-time NCAA Champion right and uh
Olympic champ and now he's win WWE and
doing fine and uh he's the guy who's 275
he went he wins the Olympics
um and 275 six foot whatever runs does a
round off into a full back layout and
I'm like 265 can do I mean since he's an
athlete so they are athletes but it's
you know it's It's Entertainment okay
that's the end of my WWE dress because
I'm 275 and trust me I ain't doing that
no more so we're done
sorry Vince can't sign me let's talk
with uh with Congress Congressman Jordan
about Twitter do you want to hop over
here and grab the mic from Byron and
then I just want to add to that man you
mentioned wrestling and competition I
grew up skateboarding and skateboarding
it's a it's a very individualist
individualistic sport where you can't
cheat if you if you want to succeed at
the trick you have to commit to it and
if you don't do it that's it you didn't
do it it's for you not anybody else well
said so there's a lot of risk taking
there's a lot of overcoming fears and
real life lessons that come with it when
you're first standing on top of a a mini
ramp or a half pipe looking down about
to drop in it's terrifying I can imagine
but you can't fake it yeah you can't
pretend no so let's let's talk about
Twitter because I mean this is this is
the the Twitter files it's a big deal
because
is the same way when you step out there
on the mat it's just you know you God
and your opponent and you know you win
you win you lose you lose and there's no
one to blame no one to it just that's
the way it is and it uh sort of teaches
you to deal with things just like you
had when you're standing on top and
going down into the with the
skateboarding what they call the half
Piper the half pipe quarter pipe various
sizes you know you're competing against
yourself yep if if you want to get that
good feeling of accomplishment you can
you can't lie to yourself you know you
didn't do it right yeah right so I think
that you know that that instilled in me
a lot of uh ideas of personal
responsibility individualism Etc and I
think you know getting getting into
skateboarding as a sport when I was
younger and then having the ability to
overcome and accomplish yourself you
know your goals in yourself with no one
in the way I think probably led me to be
more independent and individualist but I
do think physical activity and
competition is is important so you are
mentioning I'm a lot older than you but
when I grew up you you play late you
competed every day and I went to a
little local Country Public School ever
you competed in the classroom you
learned on your multiplication tables
you did this thing you called around the
world you had to try to say that faster
than the person you Stood Beside and it
was a competition you kept moving it's
like is that the math thing yeah yeah we
used to do that too yeah it's like
that's good I don't know if they have
been a lot of people allow kids to do
that in school today on the playground
we played kickball we played football we
played the game they can't even say the
name you throw the ball up someone
catches you run away everyone tackles
him and you got the fight every every
couple weeks you get in a fight with
somebody it was all good
that's a life on the playground and you
didn't it wasn't a garage you just got
in a fight because you know out safe out
safe and kickball no no we're gonna get
into fight and everything's fine but I
think we're losing some of that and I I
don't know that that's good thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time